glad we planned you coming to the house
because i think now i would just say hey
jimmy don't come because i'm i'm too
weirded out with all these new variants
and everything it was like this one
little window my kids were here one
weekend i don't know they were here a
whole week and then you uh showed up uh
the week later
and then the doors closed again right
and then the doors closed
[Laughter]
you know we were
very uh conscience conscious of uh not
being the first ones to visit you that
was you know molly initially was saying
oh maybe we should go out and visit in
july and i said i don't want to be the
first ones there we need
some canaries in that coal mine before
we show up
and unfortunately your family did that
yeah but it was it was fun yeah it was
fun what did you do i mean if i mean did
you go out or you know what did you do
no we didn't go out
we um walk one time and we called ronnie
which was
jimmy was asking me all these ronnie
questions so we we went on a lot a
romantic walk to our wives for some
reason walk ahead of us what do you
think why do you think that is first of
all i think jimmy and i are very slow
walkers i know i am at this point
and jimmy jimmy feels bad for me and
stays with me and he hangs with you how
do we get on the topic of ronnie i think
well i always laugh because everybody's
talking about las vegas like he's um you
know like he's moving to the mongolian
desert or something like that you know i
grew up in las vegas
how hot it is yeah it's hot for two
months and it's nice the whole rest of
the year but i love the idea of ronnie
in las vegas i wish there was a camera
to capture every moment of ronnie's new
life there first of all you were bad on
the phone call i have to give you a d
minor i was because yes because
i was calling ronnie so we could goof
around about how hot it is there and you
get on with ronnie and you go you know
ronnie i lived in vegas it's wonderful
and uh don't worry about the heat it'll
dissipate by uh the fall don't worry
about it and i was like well what fun is
that we can't make fun of it isn't the
heat the least
interesting thing to make fun of about
las vegas i mean i like to think of
ronnie
there's like a strip club on every
corner in las vegas and i like to think
if ronnie's going to find like a home
club that he goes to he'll be the norm
from tears of that strip joint and which
one will it be will it be one of the
like off the beaten path strip clubs
where you know sometimes the women are
missing teeth um or will it be one of
the big glitzy ones
and ronnie may be gambling at the
supermarket imagine that for a minute
just like ronnie going into albertson's
and then sitting at the slot machine
that's you know they're super they're
slot machines
stephanie's shops or something
buys a [ __ ] groceries
what could be more depressing than
running an animal hospital in the desert
in las vegas
retirement
you